I am using a product to increase GHK copper, which is supposed to increase pluripotent
stem cell production.
Will this increase stem cancer, stem cell production as well?
So GHK is peptide therapy?
So it can increase growth and increase mitochondrial function, so I would not personally use this.
I am not in favor of peptide therapy with cancer patients.
To me, it doesn't make sense to me, you are greatly increasing the survival ship of a cancer
cell.
If anything is going to be stimulating growth and health of cells per se, it can stimulate
cancer replication and can stimulate health of cancer cells.
The same reason why you typically wouldn't use glutathione and antioxidants with cancer,
same concept, I would say no to this.